if you've watched anything that
Hollywood has produced at any point over
the past decade and a half or so you
have uh no doubt noticed that movies and
television shows are extremely diverse
these days and I mean that in the way
that everybody means it when they use
the term I mean that movies and
television shows are a lot less white
the entertainment industry especially
the parts of it that we can see on
camera are increasingly not white and
not male and especially not white male
in fact you would think Hollywood
Productions are about as non-white and
non-male as they can possibly be at this
point
they've already loaded the cast of every
movie and show uh with as many people
who are not white males as they can if a
white male historical figure appears in
a movie he's usually changed to black or
some other race but they can't take us
out completely I mean after all plenty
of Scripts still have characters who are
villainous racists or alcoholic domestic
abusers and they at least want to cast
us for that so you know we we will
always have some use in Hollywood yet
even if you think Hollywood is as
diverse as it can be it can always be
more diverse because nothing is ever
diverse enough which is to say
everything is always too white and too
male even when there are no white males
left this just the way things work which
is why major Hollywood stars have come
Out Come uh come out this week to call
on Hollywood to update yet again their
diversity and inclusion standards to
make sure that another minority group is
represented even more than it already is
CNN reports quote some top stars in
Hollywood are among those calling for
the Academy Motion Picture Arts and
Science the body behind the Academy
Awards to immediately add Jews to the
organization's inclusion and diversity
standards and are criticizing the group
for the oversight actors including
Tiffany hadish uh Josh Gad David
Schwimmer Deborah Messing uh Jennifer
Goodwin Juliana marges Mayan bik I don't
know who these people are are among the
nearly 300 Hollywood figures who signed
an open letter to the academy this week
demanding that Jews be recognized as an
underrepresented group while we applaud
the Academy's efforts to increase
diverse and authentic storytelling and
inclusion effort that excludes Jews is
both steeped in and misunderstands
anti-Semitism reads the letter obtained
by CNN the omission of Jews and the list
of protected groups erases Jewish
peoplehood and perpetuates myths of
Jewish whiteness power and that racism
against Jews is not a major issue or
that it's a thing of the
past uh yes by not specifically
including Jewish people on a list of the
most special groups of humans they are
erasing Jewish people but of course the
same does not apply to white people and
for their purposes as they make clear in
the letter Jews don't count as white
this time because the answer to whether
Jews or white changes for the left
depending on the needs of the moment in
any case the point is that I mean you
cannot say that white males are being
erased by not being mentioned in the
inclusion standards but other groups I
mean literally any other group is erased
if they aren't mentioned again this is
just how it works and you're supposed to
Simply accept it
now let me uh just want to say a few
things about this first of all it must
be stated for the millionth time that
representation in and of itself does not
matter okay the idea that every group
needs to be represented in every context
is absurd representative democracy is a
system of government it's a thing that
exists in the political realm it's not a
reflection of how the entire rest of
reality works or should work so if say
the state of South Carolina was suddenly
deprived of the representation of its
representation in Congress that would be
a severely unconstitutional and very
significant problem but if say a gay
disabled Pacific Islander watches a
movie and doesn't see any gay disabled
Pacific Islanders depicted on screen for
those 90 minutes no constitutional
violation has occurred it is not a
problem significant or otherwise so
somewhere along the line we got this
idea that wherever you go and whatever
you happen to be doing you should always
see people who look like you and share
all of your demographic details we got
the idea that that you have somehow a
right to be reflected by the world
around you like you need to see yourself
you need to have yourself reflected back
to you by the world but this idea is
completely ridiculous and
untenable the only time a lack of
representation uh is really a problem is
when that absence has been intentionally
engineered by the exclusion of certain
groups on the basis of their race gender
or whatever and in the name of
representation that's exactly what
they're doing to white males now all
that
said as far as representation goes we
must note that Jewish people are
definitely represented in Hollywood okay
I don't know exactly how many Jews are
involved in film Productions but I do
know that it's certainly more than 2.4%
and given that Jews comprise 2.4% of the
general public in order for them to be
perfectly represented in any particular
industry they need to make up two 2.4%
of that industry and I don't think any
serious person would claim that Jewish
people are in comparison to the general
population
underrepresented by percentage in
Hollywood now the same is true of black
people blacks are 133% of the population
they're also 133% of working actors LGBT
people are by last count 7% of the
population again it's hard to say
exactly how many gays are in Hollywood
but it is definitely without without a
shadow of a doubt more than 7% a lot
more women are 50% of the population I
can't remember the last time I saw a
movie were fewer than 50% of the leads
and major supporting characters were
women so if representation is the goal
then you have it all of these groups
have it they have it in Spades they they
have in many cases significantly more
than mere
representation because if representation
means anything this is what it means or
should mean so even if I agree that
every group should be represented
everywhere all that would mean is that
the group's distribution in any given
industry reflects its general population
density again the real world can never
actually work this way but but this is
what representation would mean which
means that if only 133% of the
characters that you see on screen in any
given year are black then black people
have been absolutely perfectly
represented if only 7% are gay gays have
been absolutely perfectly represented if
only 2.5% are Jewish Jews have been
absolutely perfectly represented if only
50% are women women again absolutely
perfectly represented if a large
majority are white well then whites have
been merely represented not over
represented simply
represented and that's exactly why the
people running around crying
representation you know it's obvious
they actually want anything but
representation in fact representation is
the very last thing they want they want
over representation they want imbalance
asymmetry
disproportion they want groups that are
small minority minorities in real life
to seem like they are maj majorities
when you watch TV or turn on a movie
they want to diminish one group white
males for the benefit of
others but which is why by the way if
you don't know anything about America
and its population and you watch a movie
today you will and you watch a movie set
in modern America you will assume that
that black people are
like 70% of the
population but they're not they're only
133% are you struggling with back taxes
or of unfiled returns this year the IRS
is escalating collections by adding
20,000 new agents in these challenging
times your best defense is to use tax
Network USA with over 14 years of
experience tax Network USA has saved
their clients over a billion dollars in
back taxes they specialize in
negotiating with the IRS and aim to
reduce your debt significantly tax
Network USA doesn't just negotiate they
protect your assets from IRS seizures
and manage your yearly returns for
ongoing compliance importantly they are
uh licensed to help with all state tax
issues regardless of where you live in
the US seize control of your financial
future now and don't let tax issues
overpower you contact tax Network USA
for immediate relief and expert guidance
call 1800 245 6000 or visit TN usa.com
Walsh turn to tax Network USA and find
your path to financial peace of mind
that's TN
usa.com
Walsh but you notice the other
thing that the representation police
they only want this kind of
representation in certain
context right they don't want
representation and uh and and and in
reality they don't want representation
and whatever they do want they don't
really want it
everywhere like it's funny you never
hear anybody complaining about the fact
that the majority of garbage men are
white and also almost all of them are
male almost none of them are
LGBT okay yeah you never hear anyone
bring that up you never hear anyone
calling for greater black or female or
gay representation among roofers or
plumbers or
janitors or the guys who come and empty
out porta
potties is almost always M I don't think
I've ever seen a woman do
that over 80% of Long Haul truck drivers
are men you don't often hear feminists
clamoring to get more women involved in
that business now look I'm sure that all
of these industries have their own Dei
efforts and their own hairbrain scheme
to
diversify but there certainly is is not
as much cultural emphasis on these
areas and you you're not going to see
any Hollywood celebrities writing a
letter demanding that more women and
gays be recruited into the ranks of
public school
janitors now these jobs I just listed
they're all very important they're all
Noble they are all crucial to the
functioning of
society yet the representation police
Overlook them entirely why because this
again is not a about representation it's
about reshaping America in the left's
own
image an image where the dreaded
straight white
male is allowed to do what is perceived
by the elites to be grunt
work but where they're driven out of the
high-paying jobs the visible and
Powerful positions the professions that
the elites have deemed
special and that is the real agenda
which could not be more clear and it's
also why
representation
as it is commonly conceived is today
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there